and this guy gets to go get away with
things that should be illegal that are
criminal or should be criminal if
they're not and are extremely dangerous
to the people involved and he doesn't
care so I don't care about the fact that
YouTube's unfair that's not the main
problem the problem is this [ __ ]
is doing [ __ ] that's legitimately
dangerous the goobers over at L3 L3 got
Parma band off of Twitter huh
H3
l303 that's not my name I don't need
somebody to give him that besides shout
out to you whoever the [ __ ] yeah they
were people impersonating Elon Musk
right since his takeover it's been a big
trend for verified people to change
their name and photo to Elon musk's and
tweet something absurd or out of
character but here's the thing and you
may not expect it it makes complete
sense why these people were suspended
impersonation has always been against
Twitter's rules so it wasn't surprising
to see this happen to the accounts and I
have to imagine a number of the people
that were banned including Ethan were
expecting this I mean even Ethan's own
fans were like he's going for the band
have to include that it has a period
account in the bio and in the name of
the account itself and while people like
Ethan put parity account as a banner you
put parody in the bio the name was just
Elon Musk and actually on that note on
Sunday musk also took it a step further
by tweeting going forward any Twitter
handle is engaging in impersonation
without clearly specifying parity will
be permanently suspended good
I got zero problem with that rule
there's enough bots in our comment
section replying to everybody
impersonating us for these contests and
scams I have zero sympathy for anyone
who wants to be some [ __ ] edgy lame
comedian using the exact same name of
somebody else which is easily going to
be confusing to everyone who watches and
reads and especially when you're making
crazy [ __ ] statements like L3 L3
does on a day-to-day basis I probably
wouldn't watch you impersonating me
either previously we issued a warning
before suspension but now that we are
rolling out widespread verification
there will be no warning this will be
clearly identified as a condition for
signing up to Twitter blue and adding
any name change at all will cause
temporary loss of verified check marks
so Ethan changed his name to Elon Musk
and joked about the increased use of the
n-word on the platform as well as a
tweet about musk missing Jeffrey Epstein
he got permanently suspended as well as
Kathy Griffin and now a growing number
of people God damn listen Kathy
Griffin's face is a parody of itself I
don't know what happens but the girl I
grew up with is no more that's why like
coming home and finding out your wife
being replaced by an alien that's where
she looked different different
listen listen
I'll say the same thing for Kim
Kardashian too she looked like a parody
of herself some of them dimensions
some of those extensions some of that
plastic
it's not recyclable
no and Kathy Griffin's face I just I
hadn't seen her face in a long time yeah
that kill you put it back good Lord
good Lord
everything
everything
every time you say good Lord maybe
chuckle you sound like an old lady good
Lord I don't care you sound like this
good Lord
there wasn't just one or two people that
were doing this no you did had Ethan
Klein defending his tweets on Tick Tock
or saying it was a clear parody
something Elon said would be an
exception also around this time you had
Elon making jokes about the suspension
saying of Kathy Griffin she was actually
suspended for impersonating a comedian
but if she really wants her account back
she can have it for eight dollars
business
that's Petty that's funny I don't
understand business but I do understand
petty you're doing good brother oh yes
you had people understanding or even
defending the bands you had a lot of
people using this as a way to attack
Elon beating things at him like free
speech includes racism but not making
fun of you but here's the thing like I
said I am not a musk fan but I
understand these suspensions so this
came on everyone thought like yo what do
you think are you happy I don't like
l303 do I care not really I'm never on
Twitter
um do you deserve it absolutely so you
get no sympathy for me I don't think
people deserve bangs for that much
but impersonating other people yeah
because imagine what he's saying he's
talking about like I was on Jeff Street
Epstein Island all this stuff and if
it's not abundantly clear
what this person's on about
that's an issue because sometimes you
open a tweet you don't even see the
banner you don't even see the bio you
just see the Tweet you see Elon Musk you
see the blue check mark and you see the
profile picture you don't see the banner
photo and you don't see the bio and so
someone might see I believe you never
whoa yeah you never see the volume
unless you click on the profile
expecting people to do that is like no
it's not reasonable so yeah get
permaband get [ __ ] I don't care you
stupid you wouldn't want that about you
being done and then everybody's coming
at you what did you just say you said
you beat women for
how to say that you see the parity
account
y'all deserve it
y'all deserve it bro get him out of here
but you know what's crazy
here's what's crazy you remember when he
had his one weak band yeah Ethan class
should be Parma band why
the man docked someone on a life yeah I
saw that God I like the [ __ ] I like
to know who this guy is man
I know who he is does he have an online
Persona no he's a producer okay if you
don't know who Olivia is she's the loser
feminist researcher who spends all her
Day on Reddit boards and thinks that's
research okay so the way she found this
dude's name who they incorrectly doxed
and she went on a Reddit post and looked
at the comments and then found his name
and think that was reliable information
keep in mind this is one of the largest
podcasts on YouTube and that's how they
run their research department but let's
Carry On music producer and songwriter
yeah God I hope that man's life is
ruined for this I hope so oh someone
says why you abuse uh protecting the
absor's identity I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't know
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] I want this
guy's life friend are you kidding me yep
oh is this him yeah I would just be
conscious that's not him you don't want
us to end up the wrong person and the
way he justifies it is so stupid he says
this is a piece of [ __ ] I know he's
guilty without proof without further
Evidence without a court quiz so he
deserves it okay now here's where the
problem lies you guys don't remember a
similar narrative being painted about
Johnny Depp initially when this whole
stuff was happening I remember years
back people were talking about Johnny
like he was the devil and he was getting
booed off every show imagine if people
tried docs him at that period based off
the information that they had this is
why you don't do mob Justice online let
me push it further to you not just not
just mob
Ahmad arbory
according to two people he was guilty of
stealing
when eating steals [ __ ] and guess what
happened he got killed innocent
that's why you don't act upon without
having
any research or anything like that true
that's the same thing that happens and
all this these mobs going to people
boxing you think people are not crazy
enough to go to the person's place I
mean and that was the wrong person
that's crazy
forget forget doing the extreme which is
going to their home which can happen
talk about the lowest end which is just
imagine you're minding your
[ __ ] business yeah you ain't
done nothing and you get a flood of
hateful DMS accusing you of everything
under the sun people making threats
people saying this like yo that [ __ ]
with your Mentor absolutely you become
parents you become afraid and you go
after your family your job your address
they start sending stuff because he was
joking about sending [ __ ] in the mail
too yeah right and so I'm looking at
this whole thing like
breath
I don't even like snico and that doesn't
even pale in comparison to stuff that
he's doing absolutely you get what I'm
trying to say and so that's where I'm
actually sympathetic to some degree
because you see how uneven this [ __ ] is
okay you can make the argument that both
deserve it fine but you can't tell me
that what Ethan's doing is not
exponentially worse and he on in front
of a larger audience
right that's [ __ ] so just please I
just want y'all to appreciate some of
the biases that exist when it comes to
these policy things the fact that he got
banned for the comment about Ben Shapiro
but not for this is crazy oh is he a
bodybuilder
he's a producer he was a yeah he was a
bodybuilder in the past this chat ass
is he Asian yeah I hope his life is over
so imagine her these rabid fans are
hearing this stuff they start looking
him up and sending him crazy messages
and they're being primed by Ethan by
saying he's uh he hurt this woman he's a
he's a piece of [ __ ] I hope his life is
ruined basically encouraging the fans to
go let them know why would you protect
his identity from the fans or why
wouldn't you reveal that information is
because if you know you say it in this
conversation you know what's gonna
happen the fans are gonna have something
to say so the issue isn't even that they
dock somebody okay to them
the issue is only to them like oh we
might adopt the wrong person you
shouldn't be doing it period if you
don't know all the facts of the case if
you haven't heard the entire the story
it's not your place and this is why it's
against the rules and against the law
so
hey man I hope bad things come for you
too [ __ ] this guy bro I'm so glad we
actually found his identity
I've heard that he is not I don't know
Ian's not showing this and I think
that's the right call Ian not showing
this doesn't [ __ ] matter you guys
said his name you said he was a music
producer you put this guy's name on
Google and you put his [ __ ] job
you're gonna find out who it is very
quickly with a simple Google search you
don't have to put it on screen if I say
oh uh Godfrey comedian from New York
been on tour you put that [ __ ] in Google
I don't gotta put his [ __ ] [ __ ] on
screen you don't know who it is and he
knew it was wrong because his employee
was telling him which shout outs to him
because you need at least a good voice
so you know give credit where credit is
due you know it's a minimum bar hey
don't docs people don't be putting out
names
he repeated it like numerous times and
this [ __ ] won't say we stupid we
got bad takes uh [ __ ] ass you play the
clip because that's [ __ ] up what I
said does not even just play the thing
we're not 100 sure that this is the
right I've heard he's an Asian
bodybuilder he definitely does music and
his his socials have been found in that
regard well hold on you guys send me
okay you haven't shown anything in he
has nothing to it you guys find out who
the real guy is
and I'll show him God damn so so he
still wants the Ducks
Jesus Christ and think about okay I want
you guys to think about this right let's
say so if you the person that they're
trying to dox is amaran's husband if you
don't know the story about amaranth
she's got some kind of huge issue going
on with her husband apparently this
guy's been putting hands or doing
something to animals it's very
complicated okay but initially based off
The Voice causing everything that's been
released the dude in question has crazy
anger issues and said some crazy stuff
on the recordings so everyone's been
behind or supportive
now let's say I'm being the most
generous everything she said is
absolutely true this guy's the evil he's
Satan whatever and they're going through
a messy divorce I want you guys to think
about what happens when a random loser
like Ethan docses this dude who's got
crazy anger issues think about that does
that not put her in Jeopardy does not
make her safety less safe does not put
her in a precarious position let's say
if they're being diplomatic now and
they're working through things but now
he's doxed her and now the whole
relationship goes up in Flames as a
result
even if this is the ways in which
content creators can use their fans for
completely terrible things and
absolutely if you got a fan base you can
encourage them to do stuff I know for a
fact okay if I told my fan base go out
there and start yelling them a lot of
y'all not gonna do it because y'all
decent people but a lot of folks are
impressive it doesn't take 1.8 million
people to go out oh no to make just
having 10 phone calls one full call is
upsetting yep one what one Anonymous
phone call of someone that has your
information absolutely it doesn't take a
and just take one person one person to
go out there and be like hey
you know what I mean yep I think we're
jumping the gun I mean we yeah how we
jump in the gun you said we have his
identity Olivia said we know who he is
it's also his name on the marriage
certificate it's a very common name
that is not a unique name whatever
whatsoever so I just want to be very
sure that we're not sending a mob of
people after the wrong
you know what I mean no that guy's real
identity
dying to know who that is oh yeah that
seems sucks you're right Ian well we
know his name is we just don't know his
name is but again that's like it may not
be the body one of the most common names
you can yeah people that are saying that
that and sharing that account I'm
actually timing you out um that so
they're sharing with you guys Instagram
his social medias that they found now on
the live stream chat so other people can
go do that I want you guys to appreciate
what's happening in front of you let's
keep watching like what would the
legalities be if it were my uh like is
it written if we find out that this guy
is can we ship him [ __ ]
this guy is like yo you're you dance
dance [ __ ] you do not get it
like everything I told you for the past
15 minutes and you do can we ship him no
stop but that'd be you know if you just
received a package and there was poop in
it that's just kind of
trust me once it's public he's gonna be
getting more [ __ ] than one man can
handle
not for me yeah let's contribute no no
not for me what the hell are you talking
about
and I don't want anyone to ship him a
box of of their homemade feces right Dan
should stop talking about this because
he knows what he's doing yeah he knows I
just want you guys to appreciate this is
the ways in which YouTube can be
patently Affair even to big and larger
creators if you're big enough you can do
all this kind of [ __ ] and still
retain your account and I understand
it's a capitalistic organization they
want to make money Ethan brings them
money so they give the lyrics but it
doesn't mean that it's not
it's not unfair it is it's absolutely
unfair and this guy gets to grow get
away with things that should be illegal
that are criminal or should be criminal
if they're not and are extremely
dangerous to the people involved and he
doesn't care so
I don't care about the fact that
YouTube's unfair that's not the main
problem the problem is this [ __ ]
is doing [ __ ] that's legitimately
dangerous because he's saying ship ship
them [ __ ] he's not sick but he is okay
imagine if someone decides to do
something even more extreme based off
the information and based off the way
Ethan primed them
but I didn't tell them to do that
you know one day Something's Gonna blow
up in his face gonna be too big and he's
gonna come out here and do his apology
and I want you guys to remember that
everyone warned him the whole time along
the way
right
and when he crosses that line you're not
going to get forgiveness you don't
deserve it because you were warned
multiple times it's one thing if you
make a mistake it's one thing if people
are giving you thousands of warning and
you still go ahead and
get [ __ ] so my thoughts on this dude I
hope he gets permaband and I
I have not wished that on anybody he's
the first
what you want to say
um
all right let us know what you guys
think
[Music]